they've got a pivot from
martyrdom and some have been some have
told foreign journalists i mean
it's good that we're in charge now we're
going to build a proper state
but i it's kind of boring um i want to
keep fighting i want to maybe i'll do it
in pakistan yeah i mean it's nice that
they are expressing that thought
some are not even honest sufficiently
with themselves to express that kind of
thought if you're
if you're a fighter
yeah
you see that with a bunch of
fighters or professional athletes once
they retire yeah they don't know it's
very it's boring
yeah
and so like the if the spirit of the
taliban yeah
even the the the best version of the
taliban is to fight is to be martyrs is
to yeah is to and the paint the world is
good and evil and you're fighting evil
and all that kind of stuff that's
difficult to imagine how they can run an
education system a banking system
respect
all kinds of citizens with different
backgrounds and religious beliefs and
women and
all that kind of stuff so yeah and
they've they've walked into kabul and
other major cities um
you know some of them are young they
never didn't know those places but also
the very important
obstacle for them is that afghan society
has changed i mean it's
it's not with even for the older guys
it's not what they knew in the 1990s
some always had some ambulance about you
know the capital
but now it's totally different i mean
they've been shocked to see i think to
me one of the most striking
features of the last few weeks has been
that
you know women have come out on the
streets
and have stood in their faces and said
you know we demand rights we demand
education we demand employment
and um these foot soldiers are
are paralyzed they're not sure they
don't know what to do with women period
yeah yeah and they don't know what to do
with being yelled at and having someone
stick their fingers in their faces i
mean this is not
not what they've imagined and so i think
and at this at this juncture there are
still foreign cameras around
so
they have committed active violence
against women against journalists
they've beaten people yeah they've
disappeared people even with cameras are
on even in this tense period yeah but i
think that when the cameras
you know retreat and that that's not
going to happen it's going to get much
worse i think
so the challenge now is you know can the
taliban rule
and
and then this is where the diplomacy is
so important because
the top one can't rule in isolation and
they know that and
part of the success is due the fact that
they were
they became very good at talking to
other people
in the last
i mean it's been building the last
decade but that's the last five years
and they always had pakistan's backing
and so the taliban are we we noted
they're a military force very effective
guerrilla force they beat they beat nato
i mean this is
still hasn't sunk in i mean the fact
that they
with light arms
using
suicide attacks
using mines
improvised explosive devices
machine guns
and some in recent years they got sniper
rifles
and you know from the summer they got
american equipment on a broad scale
right
they have airplanes they have a lot that
they will be able to use eventually um
so but still basically it's a story of
ak-47s
some american small arms
and mines so it's very
ho chi minh
very old-school guerrilla fighting right
and they defeated the most powerful
military alliance in world history
probably so
that is not yet sunk in what that means
for
american and global politics
and now they're trying to rule right
they know they need
international support
and
the most consistent backer has been
pakistan
who sees them as a extension of
pakistani power
you know and this is very important for
a pakistani elite that of course is
looking toward india
they want to have their rear covered
right they want to make sure that these
pashtuns don't cause trouble for
pakistan
and they like i mean for some of the
security forces they like this vision of
the islamic state that the taiwan are
building there because they
those are not citizens from their views
of what pakistan should be
but
the taliban have been
smart enough to kind of diversify their
potential international allies
so
everyone the neighborhood has wanted the
us to leave right if we got 2001 there
were iranian and american special forces
in the north
working together against taliban to
displace them using
you know
iranian american and then afghan
resistance forces against the taliban
and that was a real moment of request
mall if we go back to the missed
exits um
the glacier with iran could have been
different at that moment
but
the us under george w bush
you know devised this axis of evil
language
put them together with their enemy iraq
and north korea
all that went south um that was the
missed opportunity
um but in recent years the taliban and
iran have
kind of papered over the differences
they allowed
the talbot to open some offices
in on iranian territory
likely shared some resources some
intelligence some sophisticated weaponry
and then the taliban went to moscow
and for the pit demonstration
you know they've long been worried that
you know they see the taliban as a kind
of
you know disease that will potentially
move north
in fact uzbekistan tajikistan kyrgyzstan
turkmenistan
and maybe creep into russia's sphere of
influence
maybe that's why they have you know
a bunch of troops sitting in tajikistan
i mean the one you know forward base
that russia still has in central asia is
industrial
and so the talmud were always you know a
worrying point but also useful because
they could say well you know
um in case it's how long it out control
we need to be here
and so tajikistan
said okay you know you're helping you're
helping secure us and yes it impinges
upon our sovereignty but it's okay you
know
so putin said you know
let's
you know give another black eye to the
americans
and let's
you know treat the taliban as if they're
the kind of government in waiting let's
have them come to moscow multiple times
this summer you know
for the last year or two they've been
talking to the talking to china right so
the photographs of
senior top on figures
going from their office in qatar which
was a major major blow to the u.s back
government the fact that they were able
to open up an office in qatar that at
one point began to fly a flag of the
islamic emir afghanistan
that basically said we're a state in the
waiting
and as the u.s backed afghan government
failed and failed and failed at at
ruling two right as they showed how
corrupt they were
and as they really alienated more and
more afghans by committing backs of
violence against them
by stealing from them
by you know
basically creating a kind of kleptocracy
right
um
the taliban said we are pure
we are not corrupt
and look at us we're winning on the
battlefield and internationally
look we're talking to china we're
talking to putin we're talking to china
yeah we're a legitimate powerful center
of central asia and also kind of you
know hinting that you know we oh we have
a website i mean the whole digital angle
is amazing because they
they began to and this is important
actually they they had a
website which
grew more so skated again after having
you know shot televisions and these kind
of ceremonial killings of these infidel
devices right
they said
we have a government we have commissions
we have a complaint line
they
lifted all this technocratic language
that you get from any u.n document you
know about good governance and all that
kind of you know generic language that
the ngo world has produced for us right
in english they reproduce that in five
languages on their telephone website
and of course i'm not saying even
believe this but it was like
you know just put me in coach you know i
know the playbook i know how to run a
government and look we have a we have an
agricultural commission we have um you
know a taxation system
and again this id and then on the ground
they had their own law courts
and they would creep into a district
assassinate some people the local
authority figures men of influence
talk to local clerics either get them on
board or kill them
and say you know this state is corrupt
but we're bringing you justice this is
our calling card we're bringing public
reality and justice
and then
to a broader world
they said you know yeah things didn't go
perfectly the whole al qaeda thing you
know
you know wish we could have a do-over on
that
um we're not going to let anyone hurt
you from our territory we just want to
rule and
people like us and and look
and so if you look at the neighborhood
iran even central asian states after a
while
recognizing they can make some money i
mean one of the one thing that
especially likes about the current
arrangement or they're not
they're not hostile to is that
they have all these contracts they can
potentially make some money from
you know the pipeline dream remains
alive running natural gas oil
to you know imagine the indian ocean
to markets you know beyond central asia
it's sitting on a couple trillion
dollars probably in mineral resources
that china would love to have of course
and so people looking at afghanistan now
after 20 years saying
you know under american rule it was a
basket case right
there was immense human suffering
incredibly violent the world did not
start counting civilian casualties in
afghanistan until 2009. everything about
that the war went on for eight years
the taliban were never really defeated
they just went to pakistan they went to
the mountains into the woods
and so all these different american
operations as you noted
under bush obama trump and so on
um
killed
countless civilians the u.s never
accounted for that we never we never
even counted um
trump escalated the civilian casualties
by escalating the air war
but a lot of this was like very ugly on
the ground you know night raid stuff or
you drop into a hamlet
and and massacre people
and then you're not honest about what
happened right so
that dynamic continued to fuel the
growth of taliban from below
so the foot soldiers they never they
never ran out of foot soldiers i mean
the us and its allies killed
tens of thousands maybe hundreds of
thousands of taiwan fighters over the
last 20 years
but they just sprouted up again and part
of that was kind of solidarity culture
the male bonding of
of of martyrology of you know of
martyrdom and
of
you know revenge and a sense of um
you know the foreign invader and i've
heard i mean i've you know i haven't
taught a ton of
u.s military people but through the
hoover you know they put officers in our
classes sometimes and
met a few wonderful you know army and
marine officers who
i really enjoyed you know we came from
the south like me
always had great rapport with them and
and they expressed a range of opinions
about this i think that you know i
learned a lot from some of them who said
yeah i mean i get that i get why they
hate us i get why
they're still fighting because
you know last week
we just
killed 14 of their
you know fellow villagers
so
the officers the guys on the ground you
know fighting this war we're not stupid
about that i mean they they got the
human dimension of that and yet no one
got off the exit as you said people
people kept driving
um but going forward now internationally
it's critical that they have
i mean they've had meetings i mean what
the top one have done since august 15th
is a lot of diplomacy they've had
meetings they've had people they've had
tashkent come they've had beijing come
they've had moscow come
i mean they've had
major visits from islamabad
from security people from diplomatic
circles
and they're counting on
things being different this time i mean
the first time around the only people
who backed the taliban by recognition
giving them automatic recognition
with the saudis pakistanis and the uae
and because of al qaeda
because of opium
because of some of the human rights
stuff yeah the us pushed everyone to
like you know let's not recognize the
state even though the u.s did i mean
colin powell famously
in the summer of 2001 you know we did
give a few grants and aid um
to the taliban
as i kind of like massaging negotiations
they kept talking about bin laden but
they also wanted him to stop um
opium production i mean afghanistan
throughout all this period we've talked
about is the global center of
opium production i mean over the years
more and more of the afghan economy
continue to today is devoted to the
opium trade opinion which is
uh the thing that leads to heroin
uh some of the painkillers
and even if afghan poppies don't make it
to
you know hoboken you know that they are
not the
the source of american deaths you know
they are part of a
a universal market a global market which
you know i think any economist will tell
you is part of the story of our opium
you know problem
you